hélas merci d'être là christine merci
merci vous sortez des missions va voir
ce qui s'est dit ce soit juste avant que
le style quand eric zemmour dit ça
devant vous prononcez mots ou dix fois
ce moment-là il dérape
qu'est ce qui dit qu'est ce que je dois
faire qu'est-ce qu'est ce que vous dites
à ce moment-là je me dis que j'ai 13
minutes pour équilibrer on paierait et
faire préciser ses propos je me dis que
j'ai 13 minutes pour qu'on puisse
justement ne pas faire d'amalgamé ne pas
faire de mélange je me suis dit que je
me dis que j'ai 13 minutes pour contenir
un incendie
et non pas l'attiser et on n'éteint pas
les flammes avec le feu et pour
reprendre effectivement ce qui a été dit
ça a duré 13 minutes 30
au total dès le début j'ai réécouté la
séquence il dit tout de suite la plupart
des délinquants
la plupart ne sont pas des délinquants
au bout de trois minutes de séquences au
bout de huit minutes il dit
effectivement ce tous et à force
d'insister effectivement petit à petit
il dit vous avez raison pas tous huit
minutes après à 11 minutes et à 12
minutes ils rudin deuxième fois comme
l'a dit eric naulleau ai dit vous avez
raison pas tous et ce qui est important
à souligner ce devant effectivement
l'ensemble de la séquence ses propos
pour appuyer ses propos à 11,2 je n'ai
pas à juger s'il a dérapé ou pas ça
c'est par exemple c'est le csa et c'est
son rôle
est-ce que ça ça mon moi mon rôle
j'étais dans mon rôle c'est à dire celui
de le faire précisé et celui de tempérer
après je vais vous dire
pour beaucoup il a dérapé pour certains
n'a pas dérapé mais chacun son idée
chaque crise on vient ce nom vous est
revenu sur cette grosse polémique en
face à l'info vous allez réagir sur ce
qu'il a dit aujourd'hui eric zemmour et
christine j'ai beaucoup de questions
posées parce que vous avez les reins
solides quand même parce que c'est vrai
que c'est compliqué pour vous je le vois
sur les réseaux sociaux
et c'est vrai que tous les jours cette
émission vraiment c'est devenu un
phénomène
et vous vous battez pour quelle équipe
vous battez pour qu'il y ait un débat
tous les soirs et quand il ya des
critiques je sais que ça doit forcément
vous touchez pas ce que vous avez ne
rien des idées complètement
différente de celle d'eric zemmour et
vous vous retrouvez face à lui tous les
soirs moi j'ai envie de savoir comment
ça se passe avant comment ça se passe
après qu'est ce que vous me dites sion
où il dit
après une telle émission alors regardez
vous êtes revenu sur ses propos
il ya un instant sur c'est nous une
petite précision ce soir lors d'un débat
sur le mineur isolé qui a blessé
grièvement deux personnes devant les
anciens locaux de charlie hebdo
here is more vous avez tenu des propos
qui vous valent d'être très fortement
critiqués nous n'allons pas et les
rediffuser nous allons quand même écouté
les propos tenus toujours dans la même
émission juste après ceux qui ont fait
l'objet de critiques
je vous propose d'écouter et on en
reparle pour les mineurs isolés ne sont
pas des voleurs
non merci tous les mineurs isolés vous
avez raison ne sont pas des voleurs et
des violeurs il faut l'aimer la
responsabilité de la france et du
gouvernement c'est de ne pas prendre le
risque
alors avant de vous laisser répondre et
les aimants j'avais quand même dit vous
dire ainsi qu'aux téléspectateurs qui
nous regardent et qui sont de plus en
plus à me regarder de plus en plus
nombreux que l'ensemble de la rédaction
de ces news à laquelle j'appartiens et
qui est très attaché au débat d'idées à
la libre expression de tous les courants
de pensée ne partage pas ces propos et
ne sont que l'expression de votre point
de vue est pas le point de vue de ses
news qu'est ce qui vous dit eric zemmour
quand qu'est ce qui se dit quand il voit
toute la rédaction de ces news et
vous-même se désolidariser lui je pense
que il est dans son idéologie
eric zémour et il n'est pas comme la
rédaction il ne fait pas partie par
exemple de la société de la sdr il fait
pas partie des journalistes de seignosse
donc pour lui il l'entend et lui il est
sur son assurance son cheval de bataille
sur son idéologie et sur son débat
d'idées et effectivement c'est ce sont
deux mondes qui se côtoient voitures qui
cherchent à se respecter tout en se
côtoyant et la liberté d'expression
c'est aussi ça c'est parfois de choquer
se désolidariser et en laissant
s'exprimer l'autre dans une certaine
limite